[Music]
and Birdman news oh man submitted by
Steve's paper thin lips I have very
thick lips and juicy little sea slugs
[Music]
hey that is a anglo-saxon trait all
right you leave that [ __ ] alone
its genetic he can't [ __ ] help it
can't do anything when he blows kisses
people know what the [ __ ] is going on
I what's wrong with lips it's like this
I'm Lorna kiss right now how do you know
you can't tell
oh [ __ ] the City of LA euthanized a
homeless man's 18 pet pigeons a court
rules that he can sue the city
wait they just released them into the
one killed 18 [ __ ] Hodgins Acronis
evil how does he own this is like a
crack zoo how does he even know that he
has them that they're his in a dozen or
so cardboard cages in boxes cardboard
they should pay him I do like to crack
zoo concept yeah it's hard like a
admittance fee come check out my animals
funny and mittens just the the premise
of that is hilarious
because I thought it was just pigeons
and I was like okay I kind of seen this
beautiful broke-ass eagle
but yeah a crow and a co-op like whoa he
added to his collection like this is
next-level they said I always wanted a
she's an attorney to the attorney heard
the stories like I [ __ ] gotta do this
cuz this guy's crazy right could we say
that like if you know he's crazy he's a
collector and he's a lonely homeless mom
I wonder how the seagull felt when he
just came into a group 18 - 18 pigeons
yeah you're not a good collector you've
got 18 of the same things we gotta be
different they're different to him every
single one of them is he's a pigeon
hoarder then you named each one probably
this one's Archibald
I want to do MTV Cribs with this dude
yeah cuz I want to see what a cardboard
[ __ ] birdcage ride lasts for three
think through this cardboard house now
we [ __ ] love it oh yeah that [ __ ] I
love that [ __ ] and then he and then the
doors always open at the end yeah and
then he tells people get out you're here
time for you to leave no really you
better [ __ ] Lee get the [ __ ] outta
here it's awesome hell we all have the
same version of that person in our heads
mine was a little really starts peeing
is like when I told ya I told you get
out of my bedroom bathroom office Hulu
on Stan that he dives into a garbage
game i watch the TLC show that was like
that it was like we're the cheapest
cheapskates or some [ __ ] and this lady
like she was she like dove into garbage
cans and then she would take [ __ ] and
put it in the microwave we should live
this is homeless guy and every time he
walked up our docks
he always had fresh hot food like what
he would he would always say that the
the bus bench and he had the six-piece
Chicken McNugget with like ketchup on
the side and he would dip it and I'm
like damn yes fresh food all the time
clarification we didn't live right next
we lived in a high-rise on the 22nd
floor and he was like at a bus stop if
you need it and if you needed that pee
he just got up and just started pissing
right there I can be his life I know
right I know no I was like that's
disgusting said the guy that would piss
right outside of his prompt
cuz you're selling me free chicken
nuggets hot chicken nuggets delivered to
you he's tempted I had rights a lot of
things that doesn't like that you step
two steps and you could piss you could
not live that [ __ ] life start with
your sensitive as nostrils
oh it smell oh yeah it smells wrong
there but I might wanna become strong
but you're 22 floors up you can't tell
just watching some little dot move
around down there no it's cuz I'm right
next to my co cuz I'm walking my dogs
around the corner I'm right next you go
to his house and you're talking [ __ ]
about his house well I'm in the front
yard get out of his bedroom bathroom
office
I'll be judging them it's only a bus
stop during operating hours afterwards
it's his bedroom bath yeah no one no one
ever kicks it they're like that's his
she disappears during the day - yeah
weird you the one listed there they all
like your chili you like gels bar or the
Starbucks remember what like excuse me
you're in my office
yeah how did you know that that's you
guys are like [ __ ] no connected as we
were at sip and then I was telling him
the story recently and I was like oh
that's the [ __ ] Starbucks where Bart
was sitting at this Harry that's right
and then a bomb came up to him but he
was like excuse me he's like did you
make an appointment all right what what
happened while you're in my office
Oh like he was so entitled like was he
serious place the room yeah he kicked
them off no he he came in with a
shopping cart full of [ __ ] and he was
like he like did you make an appointment
no Mike no who knows well you're in
mouth on my back you can't argue with
crazy little bit why would you it's like
excuse me I would like to stay in this
exact spot yeah do you want a [ __ ]
syringe in your eye three teeth homeless
guy Biden on your [ __ ] shoulders
excuse me you're in my office what are
you gonna say where's your lease
agreement I don't see I'm in the lobby
pal I'm waiting for an appointment yeah
like you're late now okay I'm waiting oh
that's amazing I wish you would have run
into you
you're late I've been waiting doesn't
that what the [ __ ] have you been have
you been huh we have a meeting don't we
leave this meeting with this arrangement
we're gonna have my assistant didn't
tell me
this is pigeon he's like hang on we have
a dress code here and he starts [ __ ]
- sure
never no okay so so there's all this man
here that we're talking about name is
Martina initially he I just pictured
like his hairs cops at one time [ __ ]
dead fish coma can offer you a
half-eaten lolly Martino here animal
control officers confronted him back in
2011 when he had his twenty pets his
eighteen pigeons Acronis equal so they
inspected the containers and they were
covered with towels and blankets but
these and so they also found that all
the birds had food and water but they
found that the newspaper lining at the
bottom of the cages were soaking wet and
filled with poop and also that these
birds didn't have anywhere any room to
fly around so they were saying that they
were in dire physical condition except
all except for eight of them eight of
them were in good yeah yeah and so
they're saying that one had a baseball
sized tumor on its abdomen another was
she was hooking that one up what if they
were already sick and that was his
hospital that's exactly what he said he
said like I found all these birds and
these conditions these conditions or
worse like they've been better in my
care
so he's dr. Dolittle but for like the
bum version of the bird he has like rats
yeah he's low low budget doctor dude
yeah even though like he was telling him
all that authorities still sees the
unhealthy Birds you should be like now
that I got your attention I should work
at the animal shelter that would been
amazing yeah so Martino told them that
he was gonna take the healthy birds to a
friend's home in Silver Lake but that he
was unable to provide
amazing wait would it be my home I
always love this [ __ ] it's always like
the birds were destroyed it's always
like you know what I mean like being
removed the birds from the environment
and they they destroyed them it's always
like Jesus David alright yes if he
wasn't able to provide an address so of
course because it's not an actual home
they killed the bird is that what you
mean you don't know about the seven
cardboard boxes under the bridge
well the fucked-up part here is that
they told him that he had ten days to
request a post-seizure hearing on his
twenty pets but before the ten days were
up that's when a city veterinarian
decided that all the pigeons needed to
be euthanized even even the healthy ones
what about [ __ ] releasing the healthy
ones back now possible they were
carrying pathogens that's the reason why
but it's a pigeon that's la pigeons of
course they have passed of course let
them fly free my god they might have the
zombie virus we got a [ __ ] kill him
it's like to protect the birds they were
destroyed [ __ ] love the city man Oh
Birds Oh what what's their angle then
why would they you know I mean like
they're only spending money though did
you say soberly so I feel like I buy it
I'm not sure exactly where in LA could
you said soberly yeah the only Silver
Lake mentioned is his friend hope it's
not the pigeon guy that I always give
money to oh the guy that [ __ ] the
pigeons that live on him cuz if it's
that guy I'm gonna be pissed off cause
he actually takes care that way but this
happen back in 2011 okay never mind to
think of well maybe he gets rebound it
back no what I was what I was saying was
I kind of by what the vet saying because
what's their angle like what do they
have to gain my could probably be easier
for them just release it and I'll spend
money euthanize them but maybe he could
do these amazing and in charge the city
for the euthanizing but we are you
getting I think he gets paid either way
so then that was this court that did
rule that Martinez rights were violated
and that he does have a right to sue the
cities he lost his buddies but damn good
for him what happened to the crow and
the people are there all time
is there pictures yeah there's no
picture in those nature I really wanted
to see his [ __ ] peanut butter or the
or the the hot cage none of the the it's
the hospital if I was just like the city
official right omma hobo hobo hospital
yeah
if I was a city officials and I went to
this guy's humble abode and it opened up
the cardboard box it was [ __ ] eight
pigeons with tumors and I was screed I
would close it and slowly walk backwards
keep your eye on it so well these he's
not eating them he's doing a really nice
he's beating that like he gets the
Burger King trash or whatever and he
[ __ ] you know gets the [ __ ]
whopper and he's feeding them good I'm
fully take care of him because they're
saying that a lot of these birds were
deformed distrust or does have you seen
them down overgrown and that they were
yeah they just weren't well taken care
of overgrown oh because they have to
keep filing it down I know some birds
they have to do that some some breeds oh
really like that you have to yeah like I
don't know if you've seen it but they'll
have like I don't know what it's made
out of anymore but they have to like
file their their beaks Ross's just keep
scrolling and girl he's like dog nails
oh they have like the Elephant Man Thing
elephant itís no no oh is it like it
just keeps going like the Jay Leno jaw
thing it's just like your now it's just
like your nails Jay Leno also has a
shave his jaw every night
[Music]